after a week of brutal news a little
glimmer of hope Republicans have
officially flipped Louisiana red after
eight years of democrat rule Republican
attorney general Jeff Landry just won
the Louisiana governorship and he didn't
just win by a little he won by a lot by
over 25 points and not only is Landry a
republican he's a conservative and not
only is he a conservative he's a trump
endorsed conservative which given that
regardless of whether you love or hate
trump it is looking like the Donald will
almost certainly be the GOP nominee in
2024 that means that maybe just maybe
Republicans actually have a shot of
retaking some power after all I'm
Michael nolles this the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show uh over there
in California gamor by the sea things
have gone from bad to worse they now
have a pro prostitution bill that has
women wearing dental floss thongs just
out in public brazenly selling their
bodies for sex to men and the local
residents don't really like it but they
can't quite articulate
why not and they can't quite Express why
not through their political institutions
so nini's hellscape gets worse and worse
by the day we'll get to that in a second
first though speaking of conservatives
winning
elections Jim Jordan is trying to become
the speaker of the house the only
problem I have with that is that I like
Jim Jordan too much and I think he's a
good guy and quite conservative so I I
wouldn't wish that terrible job on him
but you know the
crazy chaos the chaos was that Kevin
McCarthy was the speaker he got ousted
by a handful of his own Republicans and
then all of the Democrats then uh Steve
scalise who is a little bit more
establishment uh he ran for it he gets
the nomination of the GOP caucus he
doesn't get the votes to become speaker
he drops out of the speaker race then
Jim Jordan who is a terrific guy he gets
the nomination of the GOP caucus still
unclear if he's going to get the votes
but a very promising sign for Jim Jordan
is that he's got the support of
disperate wings of the GOP so Kevin
McCarthy who just got ousted who
obviously has had his ego bruised he has
been speaking with
Jordan and here's what he said look I
think Jim Jordan can get there I'm one
who understands how difficult it is I
did walk in with more support during
this time but I believe at the end of
the day Jim can get there uh and I'm
doing everything I can to help him be
able to become
speaker now some conservatives are going
to say well that's a bad sign I if if
Kevin McCarthy likes somebody I don't
like him just like if John Boehner likes
somebody I don't like him just like if
Paul Ryan likes somebody I don't like
him and In fairness to Kevin McCarthy
McCarthy as Speaker was much more
conservative than Boehner than Paul Ryan
than anyone we've seen in recent history
in many ways he was more conservative
than nuke Ingrid and you might say he
was the most conservative speaker since
the 1950s though I'm damning with faint
praise but what does this mean does this
do mean that now the squishes and the
establishment types there for Jordan so
we should be against him not quite
Thomas Massie who is one of the most
conservative members of the House of
Representatives he's just come out too
and he he is trying to rally the troops
to get behind Jordan here's what he said
he said quote some Republicans want to
cut a deal with Democrat leader hakee
Jeff to elect a speaker with Democrats
controlling the White House and the
Senate we must not give up control of
the House Republicans should Unite
behind Jim Jordan as our speaker so the
point that Massie is making here is if
the Republicans can't pick a speaker
then the Democrats are going to decide
who the speaker is and the Democrats
will either try to get a Democrat
through pry off enough Republicans to
actually elect a Democrat to be speaker
of the house which is basically
unimaginable or more imaginable they
pick one of the squish Republicans then
the Democrats throw their support behind
they only need to pick off a handful of
other Republicans and Bam there you've
got a speaker who is much more liberal
than Kevin McCarthy potentially more
liberal than Ryan potentially more
liberal than Boehner so Republicans are
in a little bit of a precarious spot
here if they can't get behind Jordan or
some unknown Unity candidate who has not
presented himself here but what this
means is if Jim Jordan can Wrangle
enough votes to become the speaker this
means that Matt Gates's showboating
crazy stunt to kick Kevin McCarthy out
of the House of Representatives
leadership
was pretty good because Jim Jordan is is
much more conservative than Kevin
McCarthy this means that the
conventional wisdom that we heard from
the political class and the pundits and
the electeds and the strategists who
said Matt Gates he's completely insane
this is a terrible idea Republicans are
shooting themselves in the foot they're
clutching defeat from the jaws of
Victory if we end up after all of this
craziness with a much more conservative
much more anti-establishment
speaker of the house as a republican
that's pretty good
stuff not bad at all now speaking of
Congress getting back to the actual
business of Congress not just a little
leadership games representative Jamal
Bowman Jamal Bowman who uh is known for
pulling fire alarms and calling his
opponents including yours truly Nazis uh
Jamal Bowman has just said the US should
welcome Palestinian refugees so already
this war in the state of Israel has
barely begun we had the horrible terror
attack a week ago we've now seen the
beginning of the Israeli retaliation
against Hamas throughout the Gaza
Strip this war is going to go on for a
long time it's going to it's already
brought in Lebanon it's already brought
in Syria it might bring in Iran in a
more direct way rather than merely
through proxies this could lead to World
War all right we are one week into this
thing and already you are hearing from
the Liberals well we have to take in
those Palestinians we oh yes the people
who elected Hamas we need where else are
they going to go
we we can't just leave them where they
are and we couldn't possibly expect the
Arab Muslim states around them to take
them in no
no we in the United States who have
taken in more migrants than anyone ever
we in the United States which has seen
the largest movement of human beings
into a country over the last 60 years
ever it's the largest number in recorded
history we need to take them in Egypt
which has a border with Gaza they've
closed the border with Gaza they're not
letting anyone come through but the
United States has to do it here's my
question I actually feel Sympathy for
the Palestinian people I know there's a
lot of talk about how they're just
animals and they don't deserve any
sympathy I feel sympathy for plenty of
civilians in Palestine or the
Palestinian territories or Gaza or the
West Bank or
whatever how does it benefit America to
take in the
refugees how does it how does it benefit
America that's just one question and
what the the prass migration people are
going to say is how dare you even ask
that question you heartless monster you
call yourself a Christian how dare you
ask how accepting millions and millions
of people every single year benefits
your own country you just have to do it
why do we have to do it well because you
know you're The Shining City on a Hill
yeah shining City on a Hill is supposed
to provide a light and example to all
nations in their own Nations not it's
not a magnet it's not a shining magnet
on a hill why why do we do we have to
well because you're Christian yeah we're
Christian does Christianity prohibit
National borders national identity a
distinction between Citizen and
Foreigner is it real that that that's a
novel innovation in the history of
Christianity what they're really saying
is that the United States has an
obligation to commit National Suicide
that's what they're saying and they'll
justify it based on our classical
liberal values or conversely on our
Christian values or conversely on some
stupid poem at the foot of the Statue of
Liberty from about hundred years ago or
conversely on whatever they'll just make
up the the reasoning but the end result
is always the same that you if you want
to be a good person you've got to be
able to commit political and National
Suicide they say this to Republicans and
conservatives all the time oh you've got
to put country over party whatever that
means I'm a member of a party because I
think that party is better for my
country than the other one they're not
in opposition the only reason I would
join a party is because I think it helps
the country they say no you need to
forget about your partisan commitments
you've got to forget about your your
ideological or philosophical beliefs
you've got to forget about your National
borders and identity you just got
to for for goodness sakes you just got
to kill yourself that is contrary to
natural law we we have a
natural uh inkling towards
self-preservation and we in the United
States
uniquely among the Nations certainly we
in the west uniquely have decid decided
that it's somehow good for us to kill
ourselves in our political societies I
don't think so doesn't look good when
you want to look good you got to check
out genus cell right now go to
genucell.com everyone at the office
loves the genus Cell Dark Spot Corrector
you might be asking what the product
even does well if you have sunspots dark
spots discoloration or dry skin the
genius Hell dark spot corrector will
help those blemishes disappear Kimberly
from Youngstown Ohio says my appearance
has improved so much since using genus
cell I love all my genus cell products
and my skin looks young you can have
gorgeous skin just like me but hurry Jus
cell has an amazing sale going on right
now but it's ending soon take advantage
of Jus cell's most popular package which
includes the Beloved Dark Spot Corrector
this package also includes genus cell's
classic under eye treatment you will get
all of these products for almost 70% off
JSL is so confident in their products
that you can try them yourself
completely risk-free if you don't see
immediate results you will get your
money back head on over right now to
jas.com start looking years even decades
younger tomorrow say hello to the best
skin you have ever had at jus.com
K wle that is J usell.com
slns president Trump said it seven years
ago and he was
right the Nations that are sending us
people to be migrants they are generally
not sending their best I was just in New
York over the weekend at a pal's wedding
and I was staying in Midtown
very close to the Roosevelt Hotel I love
the Roosevelt Hotel I've stayed there
many times it's one of those iconic New
York hotels that because it hadn't been
refurbed in like 50 years was pretty
cheap so for 20 years 15 years at least
I've stayed at The Roosevelt Hotel and
then it closed down during coid one of
the unfortunately many victims of of the
coid shutdowns but the the hotel's still
there it's still a nice hotel and so now
instead of being filled with paying
patrons tourists to New York American
citizens it's just filled with illegal
aliens because our joke of a a law
enforcement apparatus does not send the
illegal aliens back to their country of
origin the the the countries in which
they have citizenship and to which they
have obligations they just put them up
in nice hotels in the middle of
Manhattan and some of the most prized
real estate in the entire country and so
I I coincidentally was staying right
down the street from the Roosevelt Hotel
and before before I knew it I wasn't
even thinking about it I noticed there's
a lot of young fighting age men standing
on the street speaking foreign languages
loitering not really doing much of
anything not seeming to help anybody or
help their own situations wearing
clothing and and gear that was obviously
donated it looked SPI and spam pretty
new and nice and I realized oh these are
the migrants these are the dreamers that
we told about and there were some women
it's not that there were none there were
a handful of young women there were a
very small number of children but but
most of the the vast majority of these
people were young fighting age men who
we've imported to our country and won't
Deport them even though they are
breaking some of our most basic
laws how is
that what can't we just ask the question
how this helps us is that even that is
no longer permitted but we all know it's
not helping we all know that we have
imported too many migrants from too many
bad places that are damaging our social
Fabric and it's no knock on them they
potentially could be wonderful people
it's not even a knock on the bad
countries that they've left they're
they're not nice countries and you
probably wouldn't want to be there if
you were there
either but you can't take in everybody
from around the world and continue to
have a functioning political order it
doesn't work when that happens these
guys don't magically all become
Rockefellers and even more important
than Rockefellers all little mini Uncle
Sams who just by osmosis have taken in
the the American political tradition and
memorized the Constitution forwards and
backwards they don't speak English and
they don't even seem to have much of an
interest in assimilating to the country
what happens is you just take the nice
communities that citizens have built up
over centuries and you make them more
dangerous and you make make them uh not
only more criminal but just less nice
there's just dirt and trash and things
that aren't Pleasant and then you don't
visit those places and your community
suffers it's not a good ide the question
for immigration
is how do the immigrants benefit the
country I I they're going to clip this
out on Media Matters and say I'm you
know the second coming of Francisco
Franco I'm such a far-right
authoritarian this is what every single
American thought about immigration until
what 10 years ago until Obama
basically this is this is how Bill
Clinton talked about immigration is how
Democrats and Republicans talked about
it for a very long time Ronda santis now
has been very clear on this especially
on the Palestinian issue he said that
every presidential candidate should
pledge to accept no Palestinian
refugees we cannot accept people from
Gaza into this country as refugees I am
not going to do that uh if you look at
how they behave not all of them are
Hamas but they are all anti-semitic well
first of all uh my position is very
clear uh those Gaza refugees Palestinian
Arabs should go to Arab countries the US
should not be absorbing um any of those
I think the culture so they elected
Hamas let's just be clear about that not
everyone's a member of Hamas most
probably aren't but they did elect
Hamas okay everything he said here is
right and his position on the issue of
immigration from the Palestinian
territories is obviously correct
too but it's a weird kind of logic it's
it's it's an interesting way that Dan
santis feels he has to make the argument
because we live at a time when you are
not ever allowed to suggest any
restriction of immigration under any
circumstances according to our liberal
Elites he says well the reason that we
can't accept these Palestinians as
they're
anti-semitic that's not yeah I don't
want to import a bunch of people who
hate the Jews into the
country but why is that the kind of
discrimination we can discriminate
against anti-semites
good yeah I think we should I think
that's a good idea you do want to
discriminate against those people but
but we can't discriminate in favor of
Christians if you came out and you said
uh Hey I'm I'm going to have a new
immigration policy we're going to give
priority to Christians because this is a
Christian country and it was founded by
Christians on the Mayflower and in the
Massachusetts colony and the governor
winr said this was going to be a model
of Christian charity and the founding
fathers were all basically on board with
that and George Washington talked about
God a lot and Abraham Lincoln's oratory
basically came straight out of the King
James Bible and anyway we've always been
Christian and so that's what we're going
to
do the ACLU would be knocking on on your
door before you finish the
sentence so we can say we don't want to
import them because they're anti-semitic
and we're allowed to do that because at
least in that particular framing Jews
count as enough of a victim class that
it confuses people who are trying to
argue that the Palestinians are a victim
class and it's just kind of a little bit
unclear and then you get away with
that but what we're really talking about
is who we want to take in and who we
don't want to take in why can't we make
a more direct argument we want people
who are more in line with what what
America believes the traditional
American way of life the the spirit the
the faith that has animated America and
made it such a great country and could
make the country great again why do we
have
to hide the type of discrimination that
we're practicing discrimination is a
terrible word but when you're forming an
immigration policy you you must
discriminate there is no especially when
everyone wants to come to your country
unless you say everyone gets to come
borders don't exist the American
citizens have no right to decide who
gets to be part of the country if if
you're saying there will be any limits
to immigration then you are necessarily
discriminating meaning Discerning one
thing from another thing and setting
priorities on who you would like to come
in but we don't we don't want to use the
dword we don't we don't want to say that
we're discriminating so we have to we
have to use all of the politically
correct language well no we w we don't
want to take them in because they're
they're racist and racists are bad but
we would never and so that we're not
going to let their race in because that
race is racist but doesn't hold up we're
we're going to discriminate inevitably a
serious country will do this consciously
in a way that benefits the country
discriminating no I'm not saying
discriminating on Race I'm not saying
discriminating on sex though we do have
a lot of young fighting age men probably
probably taken in a few too many of
those uh
discriminating on religion one one could
discriminate on all any number of
categories I'm making a even more basic
point a serious country deals with these
questions consciously an unserious
country does not just sort of lets it
happen such that now we only take in uh
people who have come across the border
with the help of MS13 a bunch of young
fighting age men who probably are not in
the near run going to be contributing
all that much to American growth and
prosperity now speaking of your own
Prosperity you got to check at Birch
gold right now text nolles to 9898 98
the G20 the group of 20 is an
international forum for governments and
Central Bank governers it was
established in response to the financial
crisis of the late 1990s with the aim of
promoting International Financial
stability last month the G20 announced a
plan to impose digital currencies and
digital IDs on their respective
populations Central Bank digital
currencies essentially allow the
government to track every purchase that
you make even if you don't follow
International economic policies all that
closely you should be concerned and you
should consider diversifying at least
some of your assets into physical gold
with the help of Birch gold group call
Birch gold today to preserve your
savings in a tax sheltered retirement
account if you have an IRA or 401K from
a previous employer called Birch gold
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you will not pay a penny out
of pocket they will simply convert that
401k that would otherwise be sitting in
a bank somewhere into physical gold
which cannot be tampered with text
nolles kW to 998
9898 Birch gold will send you a free
info kit on gold if digital currency
becomes a reality you will be glad that
you have something physical to fall back
on text nolles to 98 9898 and claim your
free info kit on gold today the two most
important decisions that you are going
to need this month are as
follows trick or treat you got to pick
one
and yes or no you got to pick one there
too that is right yes or no is the
perfect Halloween party game especially
with the allnew conspiracy theory
expansion pack topical topics such as
aliens Cryptids vampires demons for all
your Halloween hot takes do you already
have the classic game well then be sure
to secure the conspiracy pack just in
time for all your spooky
Suarez head on over right now to
dailywire.com
shop today that's the one thing I'm sure
shooting this show today from my home
studio from this just my office at home
and I don't have all my fun props I
don't have my conspiracy theory pack
here CU I left it at my office at the
daily wire I don't have my delicious
pumpkin sple candle right now because we
keep selling out of them I left that one
at the office too I got to but I'm
shooting from home because I've got a
little bit of a hectic week this week
I'm going to be going to a far-flung
part of the world on a super duper
secret project that you will know more
about in the coming weeks but I'm not
going to tell we have so many super
duper secret projects at the daily wire
going we probably have about two dozen
of them going at any one time but this
is the most important one we've ever
done so anyway you'll get more
information about that in the coming
weeks speaking
of
discrimination and War and refugees and
the Israel Palestine conflict Lindy
Graham is saying Point Blank totally
bluntly that we are in a religious War
Iran Hamas believes that the Jewish
people should die as a result of
religious teachings we're in a religious
War here I am with Israel do whatever
the hell you have to do to defend
yourself level the place we're in a
religious War he says we'll get to the
last part of what he says in a moment he
says we're in a religious War that's
true we are in a religious War all
politics is ultimately religious because
all human conflict ultimately is
theological
but in this case we're in a a more
overtly religious War because the
belligerent are speaking about religion
and speaking from religious
perspectives but then the follow-up
question is what's our
religion the the religious war in the
Israel Palestine conflict is the Jews
versus the
Muslims and much as we like the Jews and
the Muslims America's never been a
Jewish Nation or a Muslim Nation the
West has not been Jewish or Muslim it's
Christian so what's our religion is
Lindsey Graham arguing that we as
Christians have some obligation in this
war maybe he's arguing that but he
doesn't say it overtly he says we're in
a religious War but he just he won't say
what the religion is because in the west
even though the West was once called
Christendom even though the religion of
Christianity is what has animated the
West made our whole civilization the
West has apostasis in many ways so we we
we don't believe it anymore the number
of self-identified Christians has
declined the the seriousness of
religious practic has declined
precipitously the clarity of the dogmas
and doctrines of the faith has has
become so modeled that that someone says
they're Christian you you you would be
hard pressed to separate a
self-described Christian from some new
aged hippie type guy the way people talk
what's the
religion in this religious war that the
United States is in that the West is in
broadly the religion is much more likely
to be
liberalism than
Christianity it's much more likely to be
raising rainbow flags all over the world
that's that is a deeply held religious
belief in the absolute sanctity and
inviolability of weird sex stuff for
everybody no matter their age oh that's
something that westerners will get
really riled up about uh Mass migration
uh that's oh that's something that
westerners they'll get really riled up
about that there there should be no
limits whatsoever to migration but
actual dogmas and doctrines of the
Christian faith not so
much and and then the follow-up question
is all right that's a religious War
we're now looking at the brink of World
War 3 we were already teetering on it
because of the conflict in in Ukraine
now with this blow up in the East that
looks like it's going to spread
throughout the entire region we see much
closer to
that do you do you want to go die for a
religious War for
liberalism I I I don't like liberalism
that much I think the American interest
in this war is to contain the
War I think the American interest here
is to U support the bad guys getting
taken out I think the American interest
here is to recognize that the state of
Israel obviously has a right to defend
itself from this historic terror attack
from Hamas and then I think the American
interest is contain the
war the belligerant might have broader
objectives than
that the the Palestinians want a nation
state and they've got a lot of allies
notably Iran to try to help them get to
that point the Israelis want regime
change in Iran that's been the official
policy of of the state of Israel for my
entire lifetime
but what is the US interest here is to
contain this war so that we don't even
need to worry about these questions of
refugees fleeing so that we don't need
to to worry about the prospect of of a
nuclear conflict especially as we are
the global hedgemon so we are going to
be the
drivers and we're going to face a lot of
the consequences of just such a war but
it is a religious war and so a lot of
people are a little blurry on on what
exactly we're supposed to do and what
side we're supposed to be on and if
we're supposed to have aside and
because of this more fundamental problem
in the west which is that we gave up our
actual religion and we gave it up for
some mey mouthed nonsensical soft soap
liberalism that that doesn't clarify a
damn thing and and when it does have
clear objectives those objectives are
bad now speaking of liberalism and bad
political objectives
California has just passed a really
important bill to make prostitution much
much easier so this this is a bill it
was it was signed into law by governor
baitman Patrick baitman of of gomorah by
the sea but the bill was authored by
none other than Democrat state senator
Scott weiner uh Senator
weiner is a aptly named of course and
because all nature is but art unknown to
the all chance Direction which thou cast
not see in Providence Winks uh
frequently Senator weiner is best known
for authoring legisl that reduced crimes
for pasts so for grown homosexual men
who uh would engage in statutory rape
and molestation with with young teenage
boys uh he he wanted to reduce the
penalties for for those men so that's
kind of what he's known for tells you a
lot about his political views and agenda
uh so now he's got a new bill out which
uh decriminalizes loitering with intent
to commit
prostitution which doesn't seem like a
huge deal except that it effectively
legalizes prostitution in California
because the way that law enforcement
stops prostitution is by driving around
seeing the hookers standing around on
the corner they're they're not hard to
spot and so they they pull up and then
if they can get them on loitering with
intent to commit prostitution they can
suppress the vice and it's a lot easier
to prosecute a lot of Californians hate
this national city mayor r Morrison uh
who is an independent politically he
criticized the law and said that the
prostitutes are now wearing less than
you would consider a scanty negl they're
flaunting in everybody's face and you
can see it the the video clips they're
wearing dental
floss my question
is
why why I get why Senator weiner wants
to do this because he's a pervert and a
weirdo but why is anyone tolerating this
why did Governor baitman who thinks that
he's going to run for president
why why did he sign it into law why are
there liberals who are normal people who
are not perverts who are not weirdos not
that weird I guess why are they going
along with this why do people feel
obligated to tolerate things that
universally make life worse prostitution
doesn't make life better for anybody
doesn't make life better for the hookers
doesn't make life better for the Johns
doesn't make life better for the
neighborhoods doesn't make life better
for the kids who are going to see this
stuff on the street corners and be
scandalized doesn't make life doesn't
make life better for anybody so why do
we tolerate that because we're
told it that's
Liberty because we're told that's
Freedom it's not freedom I mean I've
talked about the distinction between
Liberty and license so many times I'm
not going to rehearse it now that's not
true freedom freedom isn't just a
neutrality in the face of Good and Evil
right and wrong true and false
true freedom is uh dependent upon a
perfect will and a perfect will is
dependent on perfect understanding and
this is why the truth will set you free
and vice and lies and delusion will make
you a slave but even putting all of that
aside if we all know that this thing
makes life worse then why would an
argument even from this ridiculous
definition misde of Liberty why would
that be persuasive aren't we putting the
cart before the horse there what's the
point of Liberty it says right in the
Constitution what the point of Liberty
is which is that our framers of our
constitution the founding fathers of our
country they wanted to establish a
political order that would ensure the
blessings of liberty we hear this all
the
time but the phrase blessings of liberty
implies that Liberty is not an end unto
itself that Liberty is a means to an end
that Liberty is
instrumental the Constitution doesn't
say we we establish this framework to
secure Liberty I it to the blessings of
liberty because of course Liberty is not
the end the end of
society just the end of our society the
end of all political societies is the
good life a good nice place to
live that's what it's always about that
the fundamental rule of politics is do
good and avoid evil happens to be the
fundamental rule in our personal lives
too why do it if if your
ideology is forcing you to come to
political conclusions that make life
worse for everybody whether we're
talking about hookers in California
whether we're talking about Mass
migration of people who are usually
mobbed up with the cartels and who at
the very least are young fighting age
men who are economic migrants who are
drain on resources and who are not
assimilating it in any of these issues
if your ideology is leading you to
conclusions that harm everybody then
ditch your ideology you have a stupid
ideology and you should you should be
normal and sensible and reasonable and
and not not choose an abstract Theory
over the Practical realities that we all
know to be
true look at this kind of Liberty the
irony of this this view of Liberty of
course is that it always ends up looking
tyrannical after it's been implemented
for a little while you say we need we
need
tolerance okay and in the name of
Tolerance we're going to tolerate
everything except for intolerance if
you're intolerant then we're going to
ostracize you and we're going to kill
you and we're going to arrest you and
that would be absolutely terrible that's
what you're seeing here in in the UK the
labor government has just decided to
[Music]
make but this time
I'm with you what's driving
me up a wall here is that even the
argument against these terrible
policies is kind of liberal even the
argument against these terrible liberal
predations buys into their fundamental
premises which is not good now when you
want to buy into a uh a a great system
to support your health you've got to
check out Medishare right now go to
medishare.com as a dailywire subscriber
you are not just informed you are
engaged and you're handsome too you
value freedom and responsibility that is
why you got to check out meta share meta
share is a community-based approach to
healthcare that lines up with the
principles that you believe in your
values matter and with Meda share your
Healthcare dollars will not be used for
medical procedures that don't line up
with your beliefs Medishare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400,000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing with one another
members save up to 50% or more on their
monthly healthcare costs and member
satisfaction surveys show that they like
Meda share much more than health
insurance why because it works for a
limited time daily wire listeners will
receive a $150 gift card when they join
Meda share to find out more go to
medishare.com
Mel that is medishare.com
Mel terms and conditions apply are you
still getting your chocolate from woke
companies it's crazy
get Jeremy's chocolate instead right now
you're can save big with 25% off get
great deals on our famous he him with
nuts and she her not less because
whether it's Halloween or not Jeremy's
chocolate knows not everyone can be a
mummy get yours in full size or our
sharable microaggression size perfect
for giving out to friends family and
neighbors time is running out so stock
up now in time for Halloween go to
Jeremy chocolate.com
today my favorite comment on Friday is
from Nana Cassidy
8745 who says Michael celebrating
Halloween tells me everything about his
Christian beliefs now I think that
comment is criticizing me for for liking
Halloween I just talked about Halloween
with Jeremy chocolates and this was news
to me I didn't really know this growing
up but some people believe that
Halloween is unchristian but that is not
true at all Halloween is a Christian
Festival
because Halloween is the night before
All Saints Day so it's all Hallow's Eve
and then All Saints Day is a an ancient
uh Christian celebration for all the
saints who are up in heaven so uh
Halloween is very good you don't want to
go out into the woods and worship demons
and stuff you know but you don't want to
do that any day of the week like on a
Tuesday or a Wednesday or Halloween none
none on none of those days should you do
that but if you want to dress up and eat
some delicious jery chocolate that is
totally fine
obviously labor in the UK is completely
insane to try to
[Music]
make speaking of women's issues and
actually getting back to prostitution
this is a very prostitution heavy show
there's a British soccer lady whose name
is Alicia Leman I am told she's very
young she's 24 years old she's called
the second sexiest soccer star in the
world I had never heard of her before
this news story but she gives me a
little hope for soccer which I have very
low hope for
because women's soccer is not known for
its glamour it's known mostly for Megan
rapino and this lady is is very nicel
looking and she just came out on a
podcast and said that she was offered
more than
$100,000 to spend the night with a very
well-known celebrity she said the
message said I will pay Alicia 100,000
Swiss Franks to spend a night with her
but my answer was no way and just
100,000 and 100,000 Swiss Franks is
around
$110,000 it's almost one to one Swiss
Franks to
USD and she's a very Nic looking lady I
know she is a nice looking
lady
but and I'm a married man and I try not
to think of other ladies but I was I
tried to think about this circum
cumstance this very very well-known
actor or not not actor just celebrity of
some sort or another who she has not yet
named and I thought would that really be
fun would that really even if she's a
really pretty lady would it really be
fun to pay this lady
$100,000 and then you know have some
moments of of physical pleasure and then
you're done with it and that's it would
you feel good after that even if she's
super duper hot would you I I don't
think I would feel good after that even
if I had a billion dollars to burn I
think that would that would not be great
there's an old line in Hollywood about
prostitution and why Rich famous
successful people will go to prostitutes
and I the line is attributed to carry
Grant no is it Carrie Grant or Clark
Gable or I don't know who knows some old
Hollywood guy and the line is you don't
pay the prostitute to come over you pay
the prostitute to go
home in other words yeah you're big
movie star you could attract a woman
with a wink and a smile but that's the
point because then they all want
something from you uh whereas you know
if you pay a hooker in this case if you
turn a soccer star into a hooker then
they go home and they won't expect
anything from you but is that really is
that really fun or does that just make
you an
animal and you you get your physical
gratification and you you do whatever
weird thing kind of titillates you and
then I think I think at some point you
remember that the the woman is a person
with a soul and like reason you know and
is judging you even if you pay her
$200,000 you say hey here's $100,000 for
the sex and here's another $100,000 not
to judge me please and don't and for me
to still be an upright person but it
doesn't work that way the very fact that
you have done that diminishes you and
diminishes her and diminishes everybody
and she made the right decision here I'm
glad she didn't take the
money but this is not merely a matter of
personal choice or taste we know that
this stuff is bad and normal good
societies that flourish recognize that
it is the role of the political order
and Community to discourage people from
doing weird stuff like this and to
encourage people to do good things that
will give them good lives if we can't do
that for whatever reason we're just
ideologically we've convinced ourselves
we can't make decisions we can't
discriminate between good and bad and
right and wrong we don't we just don't
know we don't know what our religion is
we don't know what we believe we don't
know what we we think is moral then we
have effectively ceased to be a country
already and we've still got well maybe
the borders I don't know we've still got
maybe some of the institutions the kind
of we still but if you can't do that if
you can't tell tell who you are and what
you want and where you're going and
what's good and what's bad for all
intents and purposes you're no longer a
country that's our show on that happy
note uh I am going to be flitting about
the world this week maybe I'll give you
some Clues as to where I am maybe we'll
see we'll find out and then you'll know
much more about a secret project that
I'm involved
with soon enough I'm Michael NOS this
the Michael NOS show see you next
time
[Music]
a